When it comes to evaluating
the greatness of elite performers,
we overemphasize peak performance
and underemphasize longevity.
And that is driving a lot of young people out of the sport
and discouraging a lot of people
and frustrating our attempt
to restore the health of our society.
(groovy music)
1% of the population in middle age
is practicing healthy habits.
Why is that?
'Cause no one bothered to teach them
at the moment when those habits need to be taught.
The idea of having a standard of performance
that spans 20 years, that mattered.
Hey, everybody, welcome to the podcast.
All is right and well in the world
because my guest today is Malcolm Gladwell.
(imitates head exploding)
It's so good.
It's one that goes in so many different directions,
as you might suspect, because well, it is Malcolm.
It's a fascinating discussion,
everything that I hoped it would be.
I suspect many of you are already familiar with Malcolm.
Let's face it, he's one of our most prolific authors.
Perhaps you've listened to his sensational podcast,
"Revisionist History,"
or read one of his many "New York Times" bestselling books
like "Tipping Point," "Blank," "Outliers,"
"David and Goliath," and "Talking to Strangers."
What you might not know
is Malcolm is also president and co-founder
of Pushkin Industries, which is a true innovator in audio,
pushing new creative limits
in the podcast and audiobook space.
He also happens to be a really great runner
as well as a track and field aficionado.
And these are passions that he now is putting on display
in his new limited series podcast, "Legacy of Speed."
It's a series that tells this incredible story
behind the San Jose State track and field team
that made history at the 1968 Summer Olympics,
in both medals and in terms of athlete protests.
Which ended up paving the way for the modern-day activism
of our contemporary sports heroes.
Today, we talk about all of that, of course,
as well as running and sport more broadly.
Malcolm also shares ideas around education,
around publishing, the future of audio, creativity,
and just tons more.
It's a super-fun conversation.
Malcolm is somebody I've wanted to have on the show
since day one.
It finally happened.
I did my best to not fan out too much,
and I hope you enjoy it.
So please hit that subscribe button, and here we go.
All right, man, nice to finally meet you .
Been looking forward to this for a long time.
Oh good, me too.
I was reflecting on the many things
that I wanna get into with you today.
But the first thing I gotta clear up
has to do with our mutual friend David Epstein.
Who has gone on the record
to say that you are the world's ultimate sandbagger.
(both laughing)
Now, that's, first of all,
I will only say that there is precious little upside
to overstating your expectations in any,
so better to underpromise and overdeliver.
In all areas of life, not just in writing.
To have people underestimate you
is a sort of underestimated superpower.
Yes.
Also in running, I do that because I'm typically the oldest.
In any group I go running with,
I'm usually the oldest by like 20 years,
sometimes I'm twice.
When I used to run with this track club in New York,
and I would literally be twice the age
of the people that I was training with.
So in that situation, you don't wanna go out boasting,
you have to make it very plain that you're the old man.
Is that the track that's down on the lower east side?
Yeah.
And then I would run in Brooklyn as well.
There, there were people who were like,
I was almost three times as old.
So you already have the age thing built in
as a factor or a reason for people to underestimate you.
But then you go the extra mile to double down on that.
There's no...
(both laughing)
How does that play into the other areas of your life,
like when you're approaching people to speak to
or in the terrain of what you do for a living?
I'm Canadian, so this is a national trait.
We're a tiny country that is in the shadow
of it's large Bella Coast neighbor.
And we like to stay humble
Yes, it is not becoming to be boastful.
We're quiet and apologetic,
and I think those are important traits to maintain
I agree.
We saw this play out
in the infamous influencer mile the other year
with you and our other mutual friend, Chris Chavez.
Which turned into a blowout.
I loved watching that, that was super-fun.
I think it dovetails into a terrain
that I wanna explore with you.
Which is, how can we make sports,
these off kilter sports that we love,
more interesting to mainstream audiences?
I love running, I'm more in the ultra trail running universe
I'm less of a track and field aficionado.
I'm not the guy who's tuning in
to watch the livestream of whatever meet, unlike you.
But I was sure to be online when that was going down
'cause I had to see what was gonna happen (laughs).
Well, you know Chris.
Yeah.
So in answer your question,
part one is we need more people like Chris Chavez.
So those listening, Chris is a just a young man
who has a lot of imagination and creativity
and who's chosen to put that to work
to promote a sport he loves, track and field.
And you realize every sport that's taken off
has had a moment when it's...
Look at what happened with F1 after the Netflix-
Oh, I'm a a product of that, I'm obsessed now.
And I previously found that sport impenetrable
So a group of people with imagination
chose to tell a story around a sport
that opened it up to all kinds of...
And you could do the same thing with,
you can look at sports that have taken off
and you see some moment where there is a compelling story
that people were choosing.
Billy Jean King and women's tennis, to go way way back.
Or in the '70s the NBA was worse than irrelevant,
it was an after...
Teams were selling for nothing,
players, they could walk down the street
and no one would know who they are,
there's all of these.
We do need this kind of infusion of that's part one.
But part two I would say is,
and this is a bigger problem with running in particular,
is we're not growing the base aggressively enough.
I had this idea that I was talking to someone about recently
which is, think about something
as simple as high school cross country.
The way high school cross country is scored
is you'll have a team, maybe it's five people,
and you'll combine,
you get X number of points for first place,
so many points for second place, you combine the points.
It's heavily weighted the team with the fastest runners,
the team with the most elite runner tends to win right?
Because you get extra.
Why do we structure it that way?
Why don't we say, first of all,
in order to compete in a cross country meet,
you must have a minimum of 20 people on your team.
And then why don't we say
scoring is simply the combined time
of all 20 of your runners.
Kind of GC and Tour de France.
Yes.
So your 20th runner matters as much as your first runner.
Now, that changes the psychological makeup
of the sport dramatically.
Right now, if I'm the 20th best runner at a high school,
what's my motivation for joining the cross country team?
It's zero, I don't count, I don't even score in meets,
I'm way, way behind the first person.
But now under this system, the 20th person,
we are as passionately interested in how well they run
as we are in the first.
And the the fact that we have to get away
I think at earlier levels of sports at all levels,
we can't impose adult models
of hyper competitiveness on kids.
Kids sports must look and be structured
completely differently from elite sports.
We cannot get away with this.
We're indulging the fantasy life of parents
who wanna believe that their 12-year-old
is mimicking LeBron when they play basketball
or the greatest American runners
when they run cross country.
No, we're playing a different game
when you're 12 and 14 and 16.
Sure.
So on some level, that's about
injecting semi individual sports with a team component to it
that creates-
That is a mass team component to it.
And then beyond that, it's shelving the idea
of a winner takes all mindset.
And really getting honest
about the fact that high school sports
or just kid's sports in general,
for every LeBron, there's a million kids
who are doing it for very different reasons
and are getting value out of it
in a way that has nothing to do with becoming a champion.
And that's what we're missing
I think in all of these sports.
I've been doing team tries.
What is that?
Team triathlons where I'm the runner.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And we have a swimmer and we have a...
I did that in Malibu with with Mary Kane and Alexi Pappas.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah, it was super-fun.
(laughs) Well, and it was first of all, insanely fun.
And I realized, oh it's a way...
I'm never gonna do a triathlon, I can't swim
and it's not gonna happen.
I'll be the swimmer on your team Malcolm.
Yeah, all right, all right, good.
But I just thought, triathlon world should do,
and when we do, we do these team tries
and they'll be like, we'll go to these local triathlons
and there'll be 200 competitors
but only about three teams or four teams.
And I think, what a lost opportunity?
Because it's the team that makes the sport accessible.
Lots of people can round up as a swimmer and a biker
if they're a runner or some other combination.
We should be putting the team triathlon front and center
at the mass level, participation level,
that opens up the sport.
And also by the way, when we go to these little meets
it is so much fun.
I had no idea triathlons was such a wonderfully fun activity
I'd never gone to one.
Oh really?
'Cause why would I have suspected,
right?
Right, right, right.
Well, yeah they are super-fun.
Don't even get me started on how to reimagine triathlon.
First of all, the swim is irrelevant
in almost every triathlon.
It's so short by comparison to the other legs.
So it really favors the other sports
and codules the non-swimmer,
which drives me crazy as somebody
who is first and foremost a swimmer.
It was clearly invented by non-swimmers.
They let you wear wetsuits when it's not not cold out.
Even at Ironman level,
you just have to stay in contact with everyone else.
And then the other legs are so much more important.
So that's absurd.
And why don't we put the swim last
if we really wanna make it interesting?
And then beyond that,
yes, relays are the thing that really makes it fun,
makes it inclusive,
and also is more interesting for the spectator,
whether it's track and field or swimming or triathlon.
Oh yeah, I think, like I said, it goes back,
there's a lack of imagination in promoting the sport.
And the people running sports are not thinking of promotion
and broadening the base as their goal,
they're servicing the needs of the elite athlete.
And we have to understand that there are times
when those two things are in conflict.
And we have to decide well, who are we doing this for?
And I would love a stretch where we decide,
we're doing it for the ordinary athlete
who wants to get out and have fun in this.
These institutions are so calcified though,
it feels like a heavy lift.
Have you ever had conversations with individuals
who are organizers or at the heads of these leagues,
et cetera to try to inject some of these ideas?
I can only imagine.
I know.
So that's why the Billy Jean King thing and all of that,
they're considered stunts.
But actually they're catalysts I think for interests.
And I know that a couple years ago,
you challenged LeBron James to a mile.
To a mile.
That never happened.
Did you ever get any response?
No, so I didn't
although I pressed it actually quite far.
I did approach people at Nike and said,
"Come on, just talk to LeBron about this."
If I might explain my position this,
the reason I wanted to do this
is not that I thought I could beat LeBron, the opposite,
I thought LeBron would beat me.
So at the time I was probably good
for around a five minute mile.
I honestly believe that LeBron can go sub five.
And I think it's because there's two things going on here,
well, one thing.
That basketball has been turned into an aerobic sport
over the last generation.
In the '70s, they were smoking cigarettes
in the locker room.
And when you watch a '70s basketball game,
no one's playing any defense.
It's defense, of course, where you exert all your effort.
What they're doing is they're loafing
until the ball's in their hands
and then they explode to the hoop, right?
Right.
That's an anaerobic sport.
So you can smoke cigarettes in the locker room
and you can be fine.
Now, the players are exerting full effort the entire game,
the entire time they're on the floor.
They're two different sports.
I watched a video of LeBron doing this exercise,
where he was dribbling the length of the court dunking.
And then without stopping,
dribbling back to the other end, dunking.
And he did this, it must have,
I dunno how long it was, 10 minutes.
And I was like, "Oh my God,
this guy is an endurance athlete."
And I thought LeBron can easily break five.
I don't care that he's 6' 9", 250, he can break five.
And the only way I'm gonna prove this
is if a dedicated miler, such as myself, albeit super-old,
takes on LeBron and LeBron cleans my clock.
And then the world will realize, oh my God, this sport,
basketball, is different than we thought.
So that's the incentive for him to do it,
but no chance in-
If he loses needs to be however.
(both laughing)
Yeah, I guess so.
Then I'm...
I saw that video,
I think it has like 124 million views on Instagram
of LeBron just-
Of LeBron dribbling.
Yeah, it's impressive.
It's astonishing.
It's like it's a steeple chase, that's what he's doing,
he's jumping up.
He's just looping,
he's just going from one end of the court to the next.
And he's got guys feeding him the ball
for him to dunk at each end.
It's incredible, it's an incredible workout, right?
Well, the challenge that I'd like to see
would be the literary mile between you and Nick Thompson.
It could be like "The New Yorker" versus "The Atlantic."
But you might have to do a 10K or something like that.
He's a marathoner, you're-
I've run with Nick.
Oh, you do?
I'm not even in his league.
Nick is a two, what is he now, 228?
Yeah, incredibly fast.
Marathoner and is well into his 40s
He's on a whole nother level.
So you're not taking the bait on that one.
No, I'm not, I'm not.
If Nick's willing to give me some massive handicap,
yes, I will.
Can we age grade the results?
This is the only chance I have
Then maybe I'll...
I don't know, man.
I think it's about the distance.
You have to pick something in the middle
where you guys would measure up to each other really.
I don't think I'm faster than him.
We used to do loops.
He once joined me and my little group of running friends.
We were doing intervals
around the Central Park reservoir in New York.
And we were killing ourselves.
He could have been on his phone the entire time.
And that's how easy it was for him.
So that was all a lesson for me.
How does he maintain that fitness
with the job that he has?
I have no idea.
Yeah, It's impressive.
I feel like he doesn't get enough attention or due
for his running.
Well, he's not aging, he's getting better in his 40s.
He ran his fastest marathon ever in his mid 40s
That's kind of...
I don't understand how he also stays healthy.
That's of course the big issue with runners.
I don't know how he does does that.
I see him on Strava and he's running with a backpack on
from Brooklyn to the office.
That seems to be what he does.
How do you think about that equation
between aging and performance?
Because we're seeing so many breakthroughs
with athletes later in age.
And as somebody who hosts a lot of ultra runners here,
I had Camille Herron the other day,
she's breaking world records at the 100 miles in her 40s,
and beating all the guys and all that.
Obviously the longer the distance, that gender gap narrows.
But the performances that we're seeing
continue to astound me in endurance sports
and even in swimming.
Remember there was that period when they had the speed suits
and everybody thought well, those world records
are never gonna get broken.
And we just saw world championships in Budapest last week
and all kinds of world records are continuing to get broken
by really young people.
How do you think about the upper limits of human performance
and performance as we get older?
Well, there's two, this is not news to you,
but on the older part, it's clear that
what we thought was a decline
in physiological capacity as we age,
may in a large part simply be
an increased tendency to get it injured.
I think the injury thing is huge here.
That the last generation has seen this revolution
in keeping older people healthy.
And that when you extend the career
of a whole group of athletes, you're gonna get
the base of the pyramid is now just a lot broader,
so we're obviously gonna see changes in the top.
And the motivation, like if you look at swimmers,
'cause swimmers are a good example,
nobody swam into their late 20s no in the '70s or '80s.
In amateur sport-
There was no money.
By the time you were 21 and you graduated college,
that was it.
You were done.
Whereas now, there is a mechanism for doing that.
So we're just extending the useful life of...
What I don't understand
is what's going on at the younger end, I don't understand.
There's this kid, Erriyon Knighton,
I think I'm mispronouncing his name,
who's, what is he 19 or 18?
Who's the second fastest sprinter in the world right now.
We're seeing all these.
There's an 800 meter runner in England
who's running astonishing times in his late teens.
And is Jakob Inhebritgtsen,
the greatest middle distance runner in the world,
who was...
I don't understand, is it simply
that we're bringing sophisticated training techniques
earlier and earlier?
Although that's not a satisfaction answer to me
because it's not clear to me why that would work.
Why wouldn't that just burn out runners earlier?
Well, my frame for that is swimming.
And when I see a 17-year-old break a world record
that I just never thought would get broken,
I think well, how many years of training
could he have actually had
that would be meaningfully so young?
There are huge advances in training techniques.
But then to your point, does that really account
for that massive leap in performance
or is the human species evolving?
It's confusing, I don't know what the answer to that is.
But it seems like there's no end in sight
when it comes to that.
Maybe the other thing I'd love to know
is there's a denominator effect which is
when you look at any of these phenomenon,
we have to know what the size of the of the denominator is.
And maybe the denominator,
that is the number of people participating,
entering a sport at the bottom end
is growing much faster than we think.
I did one of my podcasts this season in "Origins of history"
is all about the relative age effect,
both in education and in sport.
This idea that without meaning to, in youth sports,
the fact that there are age cutoffs in youth sports
means that we unconsciously favor
those who are relatively older in their age cohort.
And in Australia, the most swimming mad country on earth,
they did an analysis of their age class swimmers
and realized because of the way
they'd structured age cutoffs,
there were no late maturing swimmers at all
in the cohort of elite competitive age class swimmers.
In other words, so they did a,
there's a fascinating guy named Steven Coley.
What he does is he takes all of the kids in Australia,
men, boys doing 100 meter freestyle.
And he does a very simple analysis.
You can do a very simple analysis
on adolescent boys and girls
just by taking a series
of seven or eight measurements of the body
and figure out whether they are early matures,
average matures, or late matures.
So he takes a cohort of the 400 best freestyles
age class swimmers in Australia,
does this analysis on all of them,
and figures out okay,
which of these people are early, middle, and late.
What he discovers is there are no late matures.
So anyone who, just by pure chance, happens to be a kid
who's a little bit developmentally behind his peers,
they have left the sport of swimming by the age of 14 and 15
they're gone, they got discouraged,
they thought they weren't good, they didn't realize
they were just behind three or four months.
If you're behind three or four or five months at that age,
of course, it's everything, right?
Right.
You can't compete.
So when I look at that,
so they're gonna try and solve this problem in Australia
and change the way they analyze youth sports.
If they do that,
they could potentially double the size of the denominator.
If all of those kids who quit at 12
under the mistaken impression they weren't any good
stuck with the sport, all of a sudden
Australia is drawing its elite swimmers
from a pool that's twice as big
Right, that's fascinating.
So basically these talented kids
are getting shunned or cast aside or are losing interest
because they're not developing in lockstep with their peers.
Exactly.
And yet they're sitting
on top of latent talent yet to be expressed.
Exactly.
What are the biomarkers
that they test for to determine that?
Well, you can do, I can't remember the exact,
it's a seven point algorithm.
They start with weight and height and then keep adding.
I don't remember the exact.
But apparently there's an invasive one
where I actually go in and poke around your body.
But there's a simple non-invasive algorithm,
where I just take measurements that is,
95% is accurate in terms of estimating.
So I can take a 12-year-old girl and I can say she is...
I can compare two 12-year-old girls
born in exactly the same day.
And I can say developmentally,
Jane is seven months ahead of Sally.
Right, got it.
So you just pull that kid aside
who's gonna be a late bloomer
and say, just hang in there,
it might be rough for a couple of years.
You can do more than that, Rich.
The second part, what they've done
is they've used this to do a very sophisticated age grading.
So all the 12-year-olds swim the 100 meter freestyle,
they're starting this in Australian swimming,
two sets of results.
The raw results, Jane won and then the adjusted results
which we adjust for the level of maturity.
So we can say, oh wait a minute,
Sally didn't make the final.
But in fact when we do a maturity adjustment,
Sally was the fastest swimmer out there.
She won.
Yeah.
No, we don't use that.
It's a bit of a puric victory for that kid at the time.
But we can say we don't have to give Sally the gold medal.
We can pull Sally aside at the end and say,
"Sally, you didn't make the final.
But you are in fact the best swimmer on this day.
Don't quit."
And the psychology of that keeps them invested, of course.
My argument in the podcast episode I did,
this is for the latest "Revisionist History" season
was, you could do this in education as well,
the same thing is happening.
We give a bunch of 12-year-olds a math test
and we say Jimmy's better than Joey.
But we don't adjust for their maturity, right?
Right.
And if we adjust for...
Maybe Joey walks away thinking he can't do math.
But it's just a fiction because Joey
is developmentally behind everyone else in the class.
Maybe Joey is a December kid
and everyone else is a January kid.
And on top of that, Joey is developmentally behind.
So Joey could be two years behind his age cohort
and you're trying to tell me
you can give him the same math test as everyone else
and have any confidence in the result.
The whole way this actually, I'm getting wound up.
I know.
This drives me-
When it comes to education,
this animates you more than any other subject clearly.
This drives me nuts.
The stupidity with which we conduct any kind of competition
among pre-adults drives me to distraction.
It's like, what are we doing?
Why are we having races?
Any kind of competition, why are we having any,
academic or athletic involving 12 or 13-year-olds
and having any confidence in the result?
This is just nuts
What's the bigger lift seeing that kind of change
happen in sport or in education?
I feel like education is-
Way harder.
(upbeat music)
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores of beautiful
and brilliant people who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories.
Which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book, "Voicing Change" volume two.
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration, and timeless wisdom
that transpires each week on the "Rich Roll" podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change"
was a beautifully rendered book
worthy of display on any coffee table.
And volume two follows in that tradition,
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication,
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography,
making for an exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets
and physically interact with the life changing ideas
contained with them.
"Voicing Change" volume two,
available now while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
I'm staring at my outline right now
and I have a whole thing on education
that I was gonna get to later
'cause I wanna talk about "Legacy of Speed."
Let's talk about "Legacy of Speed."
Yeah, let's do that.
We could come back to it.
Yeah, we will if we have time.
I love this new series, it's fantastic.
And I feel like I want you to explain it and set the stage.
But I really feel like it is in the Gladwellian bullseye.
There are themes from all of your books that come into play.
This is the sweet spot,
where ideas that percolate up from "Outliers,"
"David and Goliath," "Blank," all of these things
are apparent in this amazing story
that unearths some truths
about what actually transpired in 1968.
And I found it fascinating.
So thank you for doing it, I really enjoyed it.
But explain what it is that this is all about.
So this is a podcast that we did
in collaboration with Tracksmith.
I'm wearing my Tracksmith shirt today.
I'm wearing my Tracksmith "Legacy of Speed" tracks.
Yes, there you go.
Sure as we talk and Puma.
And it's the story of that photograph, which everyone knows,
of the three sprinters on the 200 meter medal podium
at the mexico City Olympics, 1968.
Tommy Smith and John Carlos have their head bowed,
they're wearing black socks,
they have a black glove one hand
they have their fists in the air.
It's this iconic.
So we did a whole podcast series on that photograph.
How did it come to pass?
What's behind it?
What does it mean?
And it turns out to be, first of all,
virtually everything I learned in doing this podcast,
I did not know, and I am a massive track and field fan.
Starting with the fact that
everyone involved with that iconic '68 protests
is from the same place.
Lee Evans, who also staged a protest
when he won the 400 meters at the games,
John Carlos and Tommy Smith are all from the same school,
the same track team, San Jose State.
They're all coached by the same guy, Bud Winter.
And Bud Winter turns out to be,
I think he's one of the most important coaches
of the 20th century.
He puts John Wooden to shame,
he really doesn't just reinvent sprinting,
although every elite sprinter today
is really sprinting in the way
that Bud Winter instructed sprinters to sprint.
He's the person who brings techniques of relaxation,
really sort of meditative techniques to sport.
Things that he learned as a fighter pilot
Yes, someone who studied fighter.
In the Second World War,
there was this crisis with fighter pilots having breakdowns
and being unable to perform.
Obviously, 'cause of what...
And there was a whole movement to try and understand
how to prepare them properly
for this incredibly arduous task.
And what came out of that, was this idea
that we needed to teach these fighter pilots how to relax.
That out of relaxation, this paradox
that the best way to achieve peak performance was to relax.
Which is commonplace now, heresy in the 1940s.
Bud Winter is part of this movement and he says,
"Oh wait a minute, this surely applies to running."
The notion about maximum exertion in those days in sprinting
was that that required the visible application of effort.
You grimaced, you tensed your muscles,
you propelled yourself down the track.
And Winter was like, "No, no, no, no,
you float down the track."
That your body must be relaxed, your upper body,
must look like you're having tea with friends.
That notion is that wonderful thing that when a runner runs
it must look like
that if you just jostled them from the side,
they would fall over, that's how relaxed they have to be.
That's all Bud Winter.
And he produces, at this one commuter school
in Northern California in San Jose.
There's a stretch of time when he's the coach there,
where basically every world record
is set by one of his runners.
His runners, at this no nothing school back then,
dominate international sprinting for a stretch of 15 years,
culminating in the '68 games
were two of his guys break world records.
And at the same time though,
there's another guy on his track team called Harry Edwards.
Then has now, one of the most important figures
in understanding he's the guy
who invents the sociology of sport,
who leads all of these protest movements around sport.
He comes and he joins with these athletes.
And he convinces them
they should use their sprinting prowess
as a platform for social justice.
And that all comes together in the Mexico City games.
And it's an unbelievable story,
and that's the story we are trying to tell on the podcast.
The convergence of all of these individuals
just happening to be at the same place at the same time,
this commuter school which was white,
predominantly a white commuter school
not on the map at all in terms of track and field
and creating this unbelievable team
of world record breaking athletes and performances
on no budget also, which is the other piece here.
They were on a shoestring while they were doing this
and going out and beating all these other legendary
track and field athletes and teams.
Even down to the kind of pressure these guys are under.
So the context is really important.
Which is the Mexico games are '68.
So '67 is the long hot summer,
there were I think 152 race riots
in the United States in 1967.
It's where the optimism that accompanied
Martin Luther King's version of civil rights
dissipates in violence and rage.
I think the summer of '67 is about as traumatic a summer
as America has had in its history.
We've sort of forgotten that now.
So here we have a group of young black men
who are the greatest sprinters in the world
and who are very much immersed in what's going on in '67.
And they're asking this question, "What is our obligation
when we go to the Olympics in '68?
The whole world's gonna be watching,
we are the best in the world of what we do,
we are young black men and America is in flames.
Do we have an obligation to do something with our position?"
And that is the amount of...
We're talking about 19 and 20 year old young men
who are being thrust onto the world stage
and asked to defy the dominant ethos of the time
about how an athlete ought to conduct themselves.
It was explicitly against the Olympic ethos
to bring politics at all to the games.
Yeah, we are newer to this idea,
that athletes can be activists and can flex their profile
in order to advance social change.
But this was not part of the landscape at the time,
in fact, it was an anathema to it.
Especially when you consider the power that was wielded
by Avery Brundage and this whole notion
that the Olympics should be completely separate
from any kind of political statement whatsoever.
Brundage, the series, he's the villain of the series.
Well, he's an easy target, for sure.
He's a Bond.
The guy was like...
Yeah, he's a Bond villain as you say.
He's unbelievable.
And he runs the Olympics for 35 years.
The modern Olympics is really created by him.
And to say he has reprehensible views and retrograde views
about the role of sport in society is to understate it.
So he very strongly believes for example
that Rhodesian South Africa, at the time that they have
white supremacist regimes running them,
ought to be welcome at the games, why?
In part because he's sympathetic to what they do.
But largely because but his stated belief is,
a country's politics are irrelevant when it comes to sports.
That it is not the role of the Olympic games
to pass judgment
on any participating country's internal policies.
We're above that, we're sports.
We're about young men and women
who are embracing the amateur ideal.
And on this shining city in the hill,
doing our best on the field or the track
and then going home and going back to their ordinary life.
That's his model.
His model is Roger Banister, who breaks the four minute mile
and then goes back to medical school
and never says a peep
about the larger world of which he's a part.
And God forbid he should ever profit off of his prowess
Exactly.
That's Brundage, that's what he believes.
And sort of a backdrop to that and the history,
I watched "The Stand" last night,
the documentary about this very subject matter.
And what I didn't understand,
is the legacy of this dating back to,
and you talk about this in the series as well,
Brundage's role back in 1936, the Olympics then.
And there was this whole consideration at the time
as to whether the United States should boycott.
And they have this meeting at the New York Athletic Club.
But of course
Jews are not allowed to enter the building there.
So this vote was cast about whether or not to boycott,
and of course there's no boycott.
So as you said, he's been doing this for a long time.
Brundage is the guy sent by the American Olympic Committee
to Germany to figure out whether it would be appropriate
to attend the '36 games in Berlin.
And he comes back and says, "Yeah, it's fine."
Now, this brings up
an interesting philosophical point though.
I actually think it was appropriate
for America to attend the '36 games
even though Adolf Hitler was intending
those games to be a showcase for his Nazi state.
And the reason I think it was appropriate
was that we went there and Jesse Owens and a bunch of others
kicked everyone's ass and stole the show.
And Hitler had this vision of aryan supremacy
and a black guy from Ohio shows up and dominates the games.
So it's like, be careful what you wish for
if you're Adolf Hitler.
And I think the same thing happens,
the same question was given to the athletes in '68.
Originally the idea was that black athletes in America
would boycott the '68 games.
And they said, "Actually you know what,
it's better that we go and use that platform to make a stand
than to stay home and turn our back on the institution."
I think in both cases going and making a statement
is superior to staying home.
I completely agree with the way
we ended up in both those cases.
You have a whole episode where you pose this choice
like voice, exit, or loyalty.
So go use your voice, exit, meaning boycott,
or the Brundage model of just be loyal,
be quiet and do your job.
And it seems to me that when you canvas history,
voice ends up being the most powerful over time.
There's collateral damage in the short term.
But ultimately with distance,
you see the impact of that resonate and becoming.
When we look at that photograph
that is the touchdown of this whole series,
nobody hasn't seen that image,
it just resonates across decades.
No, it ended up being a kind of...
Yeah, I agree with you.
I think Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
famous does stay home in '68, boycotts.
And I would really love to talk to him
to see whether he regrets that decision
as an old man now.
Or if we look at the 1980 Olympic boycott,
did that really achieve anything?
Yeah, I think that all it did
I think was rob a group of athletes of a chance
to have gone to Moscow at the height of the Soviet Union
and to have dominated on the track.
That would have...
When we think about it,
the domestic audience for the Moscow games in 1980
were a group of people who had been told
the West was weak and decadent.
And because of that, that's what justified the Soviet regime
that they were pursuing a better model of how...
But to have shown up
and to have put that notion to that lie to the test
would have been incredibly powerful.
Yeah, interesting.
I have friends that were on that '80 team.
And to this day-
Who do you know who was in there?
My friend John Moffitt,
he was the youngest member
of the 1980 Olympic swimming team.
He made the team in the 100 breast,
I think he was 16 years old at the time.
He ended up making,
there's a weird parallel with Tommy in this,
he ends up making the '84 team and sets the world record
at Olympic trials in the 100 breaststroke.
And in the pre-Olimps,
he swims the Olympic record to qualify first.
But he pulls his groin muscle and ultimately ends up
I think fourth or six or something like that,
Steve Linquist wins.
So it's a mirror image, the converse of what happens
with Tommy in the 200 meters in '68.
Well, you bring up one of the many incredible side stories
of the 200 meters of this series "Legacy of Speed"
is Tommy Smith, then the greatest 200 meter runner
in the world in the semis, as you say, pulls a groin.
And first of all, if you pull a groin-
You're done.
I watched the documentary last night,
you see him noticeably limping and you're like,
"This guy has no chance."
No chance.
Because it's not like he has a couple of days
in between the semis and the final,
he's got a couple of hours.
Hours
And Bud Winter, this legendary coach,
it's the greatest act of coaching.
His entire career, Tommy Smith has been a disciple
of Bud Winter's notions about relaxation
and engaging the mental
and psychological aspect of the sport.
And Winter and Tommy Smith retreat
and Smith prepares himself psychologically and emotionally
for that final in such a way that
not only is he capable of running with a pulled groin,
he breaks the world record,
a world record that would last I think 20 years.
And he pulls up in the last five or 10 meters,
he eases off.
It's insane.
It's crazy.
Once you know that he-
And he comes from behind too.
The whole thing's insane, this the whole thing's insane.
John Carlos is interesting.
John Carlos, it's like I have a special affection for Carlos
because like me, he has a Jamaican mom.
And he's part of the West Indian diaspora to New York City.
And he's so Jamaican in some,
I realize I'm engaging in cultural stereotypes here,
but he's just a firebrand,
he's the kind of outspoken-
More charismatic.
Charismatic performer one.
And it doesn't really happen.
I talk a little bit in the series
about how you need to have a John Carlos
if you're ever gonna do...
The construction of these iconic moments,
invariably includes a John Carlos like figure,
someone who has the, we were talking earlier
about that liberal of imagination,
someone who has the imagination
to see the possibilities of a moment like that.
So we have Tommy Smith, we've got John Carlos,
they both compete in the 200 meters.
The backdrop to that is all of these discussions
leading up to the Olympics, about whether to boycott or not,
they decide to go.
What was interesting about John Carlos is in the interim,
at some period leading up to the Olympic games,
he goes back to Harlem
and he has this meeting with Martin Luther King Jr.
Who encourages him to go and use that moment for his voice.
And of course we have Professor Harry Edwards
who's preparing these young athletes.
He seems to be the visionary in all of this,
knowing you guys are young, maybe you don't even realize
how seismic this could possibly be.
If things break in your favor and you win gold medals
or you're on that podium, you have this opportunity,
how are you gonna use that?
So they go, they compete,
Tommy ends up winning the gold medal
despite the groin and all of that,
Carlos is third.
And what was interesting about the way
that you unfurl this aspect of this story
is that despite all of the energy behind the scenes,
they still hadn't figured out
what they were gonna do or not do until the last minute.
They're under the stadium working out,
we gotta do something.
And although, it's funny all of them,
as is so often the case in these kinds of histories,
everyone has their own version of what happens.
But they did bring black socks
and black gloves with them to Mexico.
And little they had this-
But didn't Tommy have to tell his wife
after he had already arrived there and she was coming later
like, bring the gloves?
They're clearly thinking about
what kind of symbolic statement makes the most sense.
And by the end, they're wearing a scarf, so the scarf...
The socks symbolize the working man.
Beads.
Their jackets are open because-
I didn't know any of this.
You know glove, but you don't know any of the other stuff.
There's like five or six different things they're doing
that all have a very specific symbolic purpose.
It's this weirdly complex coded act that is, again yeah...
All I knew, I just thought it was a black glove in the air.
And the other amazing story,
so the guy who wins the silver in the 200
is this guy, Peter Norman, who's an Australian, white guy.
And they're backstage and Smith and Carlos
who win the gold and the bronze,
are talking about what they wanna do.
And Norman says, "Oh, can I be a part of this?"
And of course the other guy is like,
"Wait, you're a white guy from Australia."
And Norman says, "Well, actually my family
is deeply involved with the Salvation Army.
We've been social justice pioneers my whole life,
your cause is something I believe in."
So they go and they find him a little,
they're all wearing these pins that symbolize their cause.
Norman borrows a pin and puts it on.
So he's not raising a fist but he's also participating.
And the effect of him wearing a pin
is that he is banned from the Australian Olympic team,
he does not get to go in 1972, they don't even invite him.
Even though to this day
he is the Australian record holder in the 200 meters,
they don't even invite him to the Sydney games.
He's just banished from the sport
because he chose to participate in this.
He really never recovers and he ends up dying.
He died several years ago.
And I think Tommy and John went and were his pole-bearers.
There's a lovely kind of-
Well, we look at this courageous act
in an era in which courage is hard to come by.
I don't know that we could ever really imagine
just how courageous it was for them
to do that at that moment.
And we think, what an amazing symbolic act
on behalf of of civil rights and we tend to overlook
or we don't understand the fallout from that.
We have Brundage
who basically gets rid of these guys immediately.
And then these guys go on to have a really hard time
for a very long time.
It's only many decades later that we can appreciate them
and erect statues and celebrate them.
But their lives were decimated as a result of this
in many ways.
The way the popular press reacted to that,
in the moment to that protest, was in retrospect vicious.
People thought they were outlaws, that they had...
Avery Brundage referred to what Carlos and Tommy Smith
did on the podium as a violent act.
He would in fact in 1972,
when there was an actual violent act,
when the Israeli Olympic team was slaughtered by terrorists,
Brundage famously refereed to those in the same breath,
those two acts, an actual terrorist attack
and two young men holding up their fist on a victory stand,
as violent assaults on the Olympic dream.
And then they come home and sports writers turn on them,
the public turns on them.
What's weird, of course, about that
of course is that it brings up Collin Kaepernick.
Who was also advised by Harry Edwards
and he was acting in his protest
very much in the spirit of Smith and Carlos in '68.
And the same thing happens to Kaepernick.
We think we're beyond that, we think we've somehow...
But Kaepernick, he has more support
than Smith and Carlos do in '68.
But the NFL establishment turns its back on him,
pushes him out of the sport.
It makes you think, have we really come that far,
that change is slow and hard wrote in so many ways.
I think with Kaepernick, I feel like there's a division.
There are plenty of people who are supportive of what he did
but not enough for him to be playing in the NFL.
It's interesting that thread.
And the same way that you can't understand Usain Bolt,
you can't really understand contextually Colin Kaepernick
without understanding this story.
No, it's funny.
It's funny even though I say I'm a a track and field fan,
I hadn't made the connection between Kaepernick and '68.
That he's very self-consciously participating
in that tradition of silent protest.
I don't know even the interesting question to ask Kaepernick
I've never heard, I'm sure he has an answer, I know,
is whether he anticipated
that he would face as much backlash as he did.
Was he doing that on the assumption
that the contemporary world was very different in '68,
that his act would have new meaning today
or did he think he would face the same kind of firestorm
as Smith and Carlos?
I don't know what he-
Did Did you try to reach out to him for this?
No, I didn't.
We were very much in this,
we talk about Kaepernick glancingly at the end.
But we were trying in this podcast to stay very focused
on the events leading up to '68.
I think it's sometimes better in these kinds of stories
to let the listener draw their own conclusions
about how these themes resonate today.
You mentioned that pin that Peter Norman adorned.
That pin was for this organization
called the Olympic Project for Human Rights, right?
Yes, yes.
And there's a whole story there as well
that involves the Harvard crew team,
which I thought was really interesting.
(both laughing)
They're trying to find a pin for Norman
and no one has an extra one.
But it turns out the Harvard crew team or the crew team
which is made up of many people from Harvard,
they have pins.
So Tommy Smith goes over to them and says,
"Can we borrow a pin for Norman?
Our friend here wants to wear it on the victory stand."
Who wouldn't have loved to have been backstage
leading up to in those in those moments?
And then the other great, fantastic fact
about the medal ceremony that day
is Brundage doesn't even show up.
So our villain who is always there
in the big moments of the Olympics,
this is what he lives for,
the Olympics is his creation.
If a world records broken,
he's there handing out the medals.
He's in Acapulco for the yachting competition.
Twirling his mustache.
He gets outta town, he wants to know part of...
'Cause they know something is up with Smith and Carlos.
It's so weird that really doing this series
really made me think hard about our notions about amateurism
and how did sport in those years,
and it still lingers today,
how do we come to think of sport
as something that ought to be separate
from the rest of society?
Why is it so shocking to us that Colin Kaepernick
would want to reflect at a football game
what was going on outside the stadium?
Why does that upset us?
Or why does that...
I don't get that.
There still is this legacy, this Brundage-esque legacy
of, these things should not be intertwined with each other.
What is the Genesis of that, this puritan ideal
that sports exist completely outside of any other ideas?
Part of it is, there is this notion,
and it is unconsciously I think racist in origin,
or maybe not racist is the wrong word,
'cause it applies both to blacks and whites.
There is a feeling that if you excel athletically,
you have somehow compromised your intellectual gifts,
that you can do one or the other.
That the person who strengthens their muscles
is at the same time weakening their mind.
That's a very old trope that we had about the dumb jock.
That's what that's about.
But of course, and you know this better than I do,
the modern athlete is the opposite of that.
That there is no way to succeed
at a high level in sports today
if you are not intellectually sophisticated
and cognitively engaged in what you're doing.
You can't be a dumb jock and a good jock today,
it's not possible, you can't be.
Do you think LeBron James isn't a brilliant guy?
Of course he has to be.
He's done what no one else has done,
he's figured out all this stuff about
how to succeed at the high level for 20 years.
Employing teams of people and spending millions of dollars
to ensure his success,
by surrounding himself with the smartest people
to make him the smartest athlete that he can possibly be.
And the amount of discipline that's necessary
in any kind of sport at a high level now.
We've always known that discipline
is a very close corollary of cognitive sophistication.
So I don't know why that idea,
but it does persist in curious ways.
Shut up and dribble.
How do we transcend that?
Only through these types of transgressive acts, I think.
I don't see any other way past that.
It is interesting, this is such an interesting case study
'cause back to the Harvard crew team,
they had their Olympic trials I think in California
and then they went to go see Harry Edwards,
they wanted to...
These are all white guys
at the most privileged university in the world.
And they're like, "We wanna figure out a way to support you
and participate in this."
And Harry Edwards then went and visited them at Cambridge
and there's this press conference.
So there were people
who were on the right page of history with this,
and yet there's so much further to go.
We have Rule 50 right now,
which was debated leading into Tokyo.
And they made these tiny concessions that are confusing.
I dunno if you've read through the amendments to it.
And I'm like, I don't even really know what to make of this.
It's still very much Avery inspired
in terms of what you can and can't do.
Rule 50 is the part of the Olympic charter
that says essentially you can't bring politics to the games.
And we'll let you do a little bit here and there.
But just as long as it's not during competition
or during any of the anthems or on the podium
or any of the places where it would be the most impactful.
Can you imagine if we had an Olympics this summer
and the Ukrainian athlete,
there's a brilliant Ukrainian high jumper woman.
If she wins the gold medal, what a moment for someone
to make some kind of symbolic gesture.
Why would we deny ourselves?
By the way, parenthetically
the Olympics is primarily for the general public,
it's entertainment,
why are they trying to make this sport less interesting?
But there is something so uniquely special
about the Olympics, and there always has been.
I grew up obsessed with the Olympics,
watching all those fantastic but greenspan movies
with the monotone flat voiceover
and just riveted by the elevated notion
of that Olympic ideal.
Which I guess does have some Avery Brundage roots in it.
Like this is separate from normal humans,
what's going on here.
And I think that that creates that high energy crucible
for making some kind of statement.
Because it will resonate more than your average NFL game.
Kaepernick is an outlier in that regard.
But in general,
all eyes are on the Olympics once every four years,
what are you gonna do in that moment?
It's funny,
I was that kid yeah Who was obsessed with the Olympics.
That has certainly waned.
I think it's become this absurd, bloated enterprise.
It's too unwieldy, it's too big, it costs too much money.
This idea that countries
are spending tens of billions of dollars
to stage an event the last three weeks, whatever it is
and then everyone goes home again,
there's just something that rubs me the wrong way.
I think it needs to be radically re-imagined,
it should be in one place or just rotate among three cities.
It needs to be broken up so it's more manageable.
It's just all kinds of...
I think it's a little bit out of control at the moment.
And the idea that we're having games
in places where the weather is completely inhospitable
to athletic performance, it's just nuts.
You're gonna have a marathon in Rio or or Japan
in the middle of the summer, are we nuts?
Well, if you're gonna talk about
extricating politics from the Olympics,
let's begin with how they select the cities,
is the most overtly political thing there is.
I think it should be in Oslo,
they have a ton of money the Norwegians.
I don't know if they have enough hotel rooms.
But the weather's nice and cool in the summer.
Stick it in Oslo and just say,
we're all going to Oslo every four years.
And shouldn't it just be in Athens for very summer again?
No, cause it's too hot, Rich.
Yeah, but that is the history of the games, right?
But you can make it impossible
for people to run their events.
Was it Mexico City in like October?
Yeah, it was pushed.
It was weird, it was later in the year.
Because they wanted the Mexico...
There's many reasons.
One rumored thing is the Mexican government
needed more time to get there.
The country was being racked by protests
and they wanted a chance to get it under control.
But I thought it was also-
Which has to do with the money being spent
on the Olympic games and not on the populace.
But would there be a weather reason?
No, because Mexico City's at altitude,
so not a terribly hot place in the summer.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants, more fruits,
vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is The Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable, all in one, digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super-delicious, and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff people.
For just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com, promo code RRHEALTH
for $10 off in annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
The other character that we haven't talked about
is Lee Evans, and he creates a no win situation for himself
despite winning a gold medal.
Well, he had the bad fortune to come after the 200 meters.
So he's a 400 meter runner
and the world's greatest 400 meter runner at the time.
And his final is after the 200 meters.
So after basically Carlos and Tommy Smith
have burned the place down
and the whole world is in uproar over what they've done-
They're sent home.
They're sent home and Evans is left-
If they weren't sent home, the US team
was looking at possibly the entire team having to go.
Being expelled.
Would Brundage really have done that,
I haven't thought about that.
He would've destroyed the games to do that.
So everyone's looking at Smith's and is like, or at Evans
and is like, "All right Lee, you're up next,
you're part of the same group.
You're probably gonna win the gold medal,
What are you gonna do on the stand?"
And he has a full-fledged breakdown before the 400 meters.
This crowd of journalists mobbing him and there's like...
Bud Winter takes him aside
and does the same thing he had to do with Tommy Smith,
nurses him back to psychological health before the final.
And Bud Winter has this, he says turns to him at one point,
this is like hours before the final and said,
"Lee, you couldn't run to the corner store
to get a pint of milk right now."
That's how he's just overwhelmed
with the pressure of the moment.
And he takes him back to his room
and they go through all their meditative techniques
and he restores his state of mind.
And Evan goes out there and sets a world record
that would not be broken for I think more than 20 years.
It was one of the great track and field gold medals.
He just has a sensational performance.
And he does on the victory stand
a muted version of the protest that Smith and Carlos do.
He kind of finds a middle ground.
But it's just a kind of...
So he doesn't produce the iconic moment
that Smith and Carlos does.
But he doesn't have to because what he's saying is
he continues the tradition and makes it plain
that he's also making a statement.
A couple of observations on that.
First, the pressure alone
just to perform at the Olympic games
when you're expected to win a gold medal
is beyond what most of us can imagine.
And then to layer on top of that
all the political ramifications
of what he might or might not do on the podium,
how do you not have your head just explode?
They're worried they're gonna get shot,
they're getting death threats left and right.
They think that when he stand up on that podium,
someone's gonna take out a gun and a sniper is gonna...
They're really-
The thing with Tommy.
When he pulled his groin,
he thought that he might have been shot.
Yeah, that was a legit fear.
How crazy is that?
A legit fear for a runner in a race at the Olympics
is that someone's gonna take them out,
someone's gonna kill them.
But it takes us back to '68,
not only was the long hot summer in America '67,
where the whole country seemed like they were in flames.
But just weeks before the Olympic games in Mexico,
the city was in lockdown,
there was a massacre 10 days before the games opened.
There's a massacre at a big square in Mexico City,
where the army just takes out a bunch of students
who are protesting.
We don't know how many were killed in that,
but it could have been over 100 people.
It's just hard for us to wrap our minds
around how crazy that period was.
And here are these, and they're...
I don't use the word kids lightly,
but Evans and Smith and Carlos, they're 19 and 20 years old.
And they're suddenly thrust onto the world stage
in the middle of all of this maelstrom.
The whole thing just blows me away.
So Evans wears a beret as he's walking up onto the podium.
But then he takes it off off when they play the Anthem.
So that becomes a situation in which
certain people think that he went too far
and another group of people think that he didn't do enough.
So he's really pleasing nobody in this act in the moment.
And then has a really hard time for the rest of his life.
These guys can't get jobs, they really suffer.
They pay the price in a really material way.
No, the sacrifice is real in a way that it's...
It was just, you're angry black men, go away.
And there's a whole debate over what the fist meant,
did it mean black power?
Lee Evans was saying that I'm doing...
That was a Black Panther move, to wear the beret.
Whereas Tommy and John, they were trying to convey
this sense of solidarity with humanity
that got twisted and misinterpreted.
It's important to remember just what a kind of bogeyman
the Black Panther movement was in the late '60s.
Many white Americans were truly terrified,
of the notion that there would be a armed, radical,
violent part of the civil rights movement.
And that's what the Black Panthers were,
they were the radical arm of this fight for social justice.
And they did engage in acts of violence
and people were completely terrified of them.
So the idea that Lee Evans
would employ symbolism of the Black Panthers
as he made his way to the podium in the 400 meters,
it freaked a lot of people out.
It's interesting when you think about that
in juxtaposition with modern day versions of this.
Like I'm thinking of Steve Kerr's press conference
and how that really just seemed to resonate
across the board in a powerful way.
And he's a white man, so it's different qualitatively.
But does that happen without the legacy
of all these prior acts of courage?
I don't think it does.
Kerr's interesting and special cause his own father,
of course, was assassinated in a terrorist act.
And although my reaction to Kerr I always wonder
why so few NFL and NBA coaches don't follow his lead.
He does seem like he's still a little bit lonely out there
when he makes those stands.
Greg Popovich has made it clear that he belongs
on the same side as Steve Kerr.
But there's a long list of NBA coaches
who keep their mouth shut, I don't know why.
And it's interesting,
the differences between the various professional leagues,
like the NBA versus the NFL.
Which is a very different animal altogether
because of its customer base essentially.
No, the the NFL,
I always feel like the apocalypse could come,
global warming could wipe out all of humanity,
and the NFL will still be playing its games on Sunday.
I feel like (both laugh) there's something about them
that's never, ever gonna change.
And it's also interesting how the modern day athlete,
activist is showing up now,
it's mostly about mental health now
when these transgressive acts,
like you have Simone Biles and Naomi Osaka taking a stand
for their own personal wellbeing.
How do you think about that in relationship to the history?
Well, I have to say that
there was no controversy in recent Olympic history
that baffled me as much as the amount of hostility
that Simone Biles attracted
when she dropped out of that event.
To this day I don't get it.
Well I think when you think about the amateur ideal,
then it would be the purview of the athlete
to make that choice because they are an amateur.
But now it is so commercialized and comodified,
these people are a product and they're expected to perform.
And we as the audience are demanding of that.
But she's the greatest there ever was.
This is what I don't understand,
at what point shouldn't she earn?
So I don't understand anyone, for example,
who would feel they have standing
to criticize a decision she makes about her own performance.
She's the best there ever was.
It would be like me criticizing Michael Jordan
over the way he shot a jump shot.
He's Michael Jordan, you can't criticize.
You're not qualified to make that jump shot.
She's the GOAT,
and she's doing something which is not a...
She's engaged in a sport which is nuts.
It's like the most dangerous high wire act
and she's doing stuff that no one
in the history of the world has ever done in gymnastics.
She makes a call, she has an experience that shakes her
and shakes her, this is the toughest athlete
that ever walked into a gymnastics arena.
And she says, "It's in my own best interest not to go on."
I would have thought that we would all have just sat there
and said, "Oh my God, tell us more, what can we learn?"
And then instead, what she gets
is this tidal wave of criticism
from people who probably haven't even strapped down
a pair of running shoes in the last 15 years.
I was like, this was one of the lowest moments
in American public discourse in a very long time.
So what is that?
Is it this sense, this archaic sense
that if you're a true competitor,
you don't opt out of difficult scenarios?
What is the antecedent of that?
Part of this is this idea, and it goes back to Bud Winter,
Bud Winter, when he reinvents sprinting,
he's confronting a kind of intuitive notion
about what effort looks like.
And his point is that our intuitive notion,
that in order to get the most
out of any kind of physical exertion,
you have to display obvious effort,
he said that notion is false,
that paradoxically, the best way to run
as fast as you can possibly run
is not to look like you're running as fast
and not to act as if you're trying to run as fast as you...
That through relaxation, comes peak performance.
The root of that intuitive notion,
that you need to look like you're...
The thing that he was trying to confront
is this idea that you can grit and grimace your way
through the perseverance even in the face of of pain
or difficulty is always the best course,
that that's what a hero is, the person who perseveres.
And we know real athletes know that to be false.
If you get an injury,
the first thing you should do is stop not persevere.
Perseverance is sometimes useful,
but elite athletes know the difference
between wise and unwise perseverance.
I think that there's a class of people
who didn't appreciate that distinction.
No one has persevered more than Simone Biles,
but she perseveres wisely, she doesn't persevere unwisely.
There's a troglodyte, pre-21st century, pre-20th century
notion that doesn't make that crucial distinction.
There's also, I think, a sense of ownership.
Like we have, you talk about standing,
but have this expectation and you need to jump
when we say jump.
A strange relationship
between audience and athlete that is perverse.
Yeah, there is that is interesting.
That the fan, by virtue of their fandom,
feels they have some ownership of the athlete.
But it's also a weird idea.
I know, I know.
The other thing about Bud Winter,
is he's also doing visualization right?
Yeah.
That's key
to any athlete now that's part and parcel of the ABCs
of preparing for your sport.
But that was revolutionary at the time too,
this idea of can you be present?
Can you walk through...
The whole mental game begins with him.
And he teaches it so powerfully
that he got a guy with a groin pull to set a world record
in 200 meters (both laugh).
I'd one groin problem in my life, it was so terrible.
And it takes like nine months for it to heal, right?
Exactly, that is right (laughs).
And he just takes him out on the track and calms him down
and they do some 60% efforts, some 80% efforts,
gets his mind right.
And then it's so beautiful
how Tommy walks through second by second
him being on the starting blocks,
not being able to warm up his starts like everybody else,
not knowing what's gonna happen.
But when the gun goes off, all the training comes into play
and his aperture just narrows down
to what he knows how to do through-
But it's really interesting
because his injury forces him to do
the very thing that Winter's trying to do,
which is the best way to run it 100% is not to run it 100%.
So he's holding himself back
and the result of just a little bit,
he won't go right to the...
Which would be the danger in the Olympic final,
is that you do push yourself too far,
particularly in a sport like sprinting.
So he can't do that.
So in a weird way, maybe he's freed up
to have the greatest performance of his life.
Which is an interesting thing with running in general.
Because so much of running is about holding back, economy.
So this is funny, I once had a conversation,
I won't use his name, with a Nobel prize winning economist
who you've probably heard of, who I genuinely like,
I've done it for a long time.
He's a brilliant lovely guy, not an athlete.
And he said, we were talking about running
and we're talking about middle distance running.
He was like he found it all baffling, he said,
"I don't understand why you just don't go out
and run as hard as you can for as long as you can."
And he thought like...
And I was incapable of explaining to him why that was wrong,
I couldn't do it, I couldn't.
Imagine a guy who's never exercised a day in his life
but has an IQ of 200, he's a purely rational.
He was like, "Well you have X amount of energy.
Surely the danger is that, you have 100 points of energy,
the danger is you'll finish the race
and you'll only have used 90.
So the best way to ensure you use all 100
is just to go as hard as you can for as long as you can.
But that's the same mistake you can make with F1.
Well, just get out there
and drive faster than the other guy.
And then you learn, oh my God, this is so complex
and there's so much strategy here
and the tires and all the stuff,
and you realize it's not about that at all.
The great privilege of being a journalist
is that you learn, in the best possible way,
how large gap is between lay understanding of some field
and expert understanding.
If you're a layperson under normal circumstances,
I think you think that gap is smaller than it actually is.
You think, yeah,
my doctor knows more about medicine than I do.
But I did a Google search before I came,
and I'm pretty sure what I have is this
and doctor says I don't.
And like, "Are you sure doctor?"
We think it's a narrow difference between...
When you're a journalist and you report stories,
what you get is a reminder
every time you pick up the phone and do an interview,
that your knowledge is way down here
and the person you're talking to's knowledge is way up here.
And that gap is 10 times larger than you thought it was
when you picked up the phone.
That's the great gift of journalism, it is an act,
it is a discipline that reinforces humility at every turn.
What's the theory, the Dunning Kruger effect,
where the less you know,
the more you think you have command over terrain.
Journalism is reversed Dunning Kruger.
Yeah, good for the soul.
When your curiosity is piqued
and you think, this is something I wanna learn more about
and you go into that interviewer mode,
what is your strategy or super-power as an interviewer
to get the best out of the person that you're talking to?
Ask dumb questions.
Which is an act of humility, right?
Yes, yes.
Because you'll discover that very often
what you thought was a dumb question's not dumb at all
and that the knowledge you presume you already have,
you probably don't have.
I try not to overs script interviews
because the most value in an interview
comes from the unexpected places
the person that you're talking to goes.
Which again, is a version of the same thing,
don't pretend you know.
Sometimes I interview people
or I see people who are preparing for an interview
and they have 25 questions written out and I think-
I'm closing my outline right now.
Which is just my security blanket anyway.
No, it's useful, it's useful, it's useful.
But I always say, are you really so sure
that you know the direction the conversation's gonna go?
And so, are you sure you want to direct the conversation?
Whatever happened to listening
and to responding and improv?
The best interviews
have an element of improvisation in them.
And I'm thinking of some of the ones I did
for this season of "Revisionist History"
where there was some kind of surprising turn,
often it's with emotion,
that you won't understand the parts of the story
that you're eliciting from someone,
that have a great emotional meaning to them.
You've have no way of knowing.
And then when that happens, you need to be prepared to pause
and reflect on that emotion as opposed to...
The rookie era in interviewing is that
people are so in a hurry to get to the next question
that they don't-
Of course.
Pause.
We've both been guests on podcasts
where somebody has their list.
They're not listening to what you say.
You answer the question, they say awesome,
and then they ask the next,
they're thinking about the next question
The problem that I always run into is,
obviously I talk to people and this is what I do,
when it's somebody like yourself
that I'm really excited to talk to,
I do have a tendency to over prepare
'cause wanna be on top of everything.
And it does rob the experience of any surprise.
If I already know too much, then it boxes you into a corner
and where do you go from that?
But it takes a level of security to hold yourself back.
Like in running, I'm gonna hold myself back.
I know I could read all this other stuff,
but I'm not gonna do that.
Do I have enough confidence in my conversational ability
to just show up and be present and listen?
You go to a dinner party,
you don't prepare for a dinner party,
you go and you engage with the person.
Can we have that type of experience and trust
that it will go in the direction that it needs to go?
Well, but I don't want you to be too hard on yourself.
if I'm-
But if I'm doing it,
I'm gonna obviously listen to the podcast
and understand the terrain and the subject matter.
It would be disrespectful to you,
who's going out of your way to come here and spend time,
to not do that.
The way I would phrase it is that,
the best kind of preparation
is it simply allows you to understand
all the things that you don't know.
So for example, if I'm talking to some scientist
who's written a research paper,
I would totally read the research paper first,
but that's only to generate a whole series of questions.
Invariably, deep reading of anyone's work
usually gives you an insight
into all the things that you don't know,
the further things, the things that were left unsaid,
the assumptions that weren't.
People's research or people's work
is only an approximation of their knowledge,
it's a little window.
So if I know, oh okay, I can see this little piece of it,
then I know oh, I need to ask questions
about all of the hidden underpinnings.
And then you take all of that
and you do your Gladwellian synthesis, like only you can do,
to create these works, whether written or audio.
And I wanted to talk a little bit about the advent,
like this explosion in creative audio
that you're at the center of.
I think it's so interesting,
especially in context to legacy publishing,
what's broken about that, where they're myopic
about where modern audiences place their attention.
Well, I got interested in rethinking audio because
when I got to New York 20 some odd years ago,
I'd ride the subway
and everyone would be reading magazines and books.
And then five years ago, get in a subway
and everyone was listening to something with their ears.
And I realized, oh, I've just lost an audience.
And if I don't move from the eyes to the ears,
I'm out of a job.
Or at least not out of a job,
there's a whole group of people that I'm just gonna miss.
Then my question was, well, why are the things
that we're giving them to listen to so bad?
You write a book and you just read the book
into a microphone in a closet.
Horrible.
What's that?
It's horrible
It's horrible.
Most of those experiences
are terrible.
They're terrible.
And they're generally worse
with some overly trained voice actor reading them.
It is amazing.
So we decided let's do real stuff,
stuff that's worthy of being listened to.
So it can be as simple as, in my book
"Talking to Strangers," it was like a podcast.
All of the interviews I did, I have tape,
and I used that tape, and I used archival tape.
If I'm talking about general so-and-so,
you hear general so-and-so,
you don't hear me saying he said this.
When I'm talking about some special bomber,
you're gonna hear the bomber.
We did that whole...
It's not just a matter of taking
what would be appropriate in book form
and just vocalizing it.
These are different mediums that have different priorities
in terms of how you bring the best
out of this story that you're trying to tell.
They have very different...
Audio is so much more emotional that it changes,
if you're gonna think in terms of telling a story in audio,
it changes the kind of story that you can tell.
So when I think about podcast episodes,
the best podcast episodes I do in "Revisionist History"
are episodes that could not be done in print.
Just the story wouldn't work, wouldn't be interesting,
and vice versa.
Now, there are some that can work
but they tend to be B-level podcast episodes.
The great ones, like I did it one a couple years ago
on Elvis, there's a song that Elvis sang.
And he would always botch the lyrics of it.
The one with Jack White.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, with Jack White.
That's one, you can write that,
it would be interesting kind of.
You had to hear it, you gotta hear Elvis,
you gotta hear Jack.
I'm in the studio with Jack White,
there's this woman named Casey Bowls,
who sings a song in the middle of that,
where she breaks down in the middle of the thing,
everyone's crying.
It was just this nuts thing.
But you have to hear it, it doesn't work on the page,
that's the gold standard.
Yeah, very difficult to achieve that.
I think people underappreciate how hard it is
to do what you do.
You're essentially making documentaries without cameras
You need a team of incredibly skilled people.
I'm sure it's unbelievably time intensive and expensive
and very different from the writing process
of you going out, interviewing people,
and sitting at your desk and writing something,
this is a team effort, right?
So suddenly you have to be a manager of people
and you have to be in meetings.
And it's a whole different personality trait
that you have to leverage to make these things.
It's also really fun, it's really fun.
I heard you say something like,
"Now you have to be in all these meetings and you're like,
'This is fantastic, I get to talk to people.'"
Most writers are like
they've completely constructed their lives to avoid that.
I have a great team and we have a lot of fun.
And every year, we try and do a reporting trip,
I take two of my producers.
Last year, we went, cause I did an episode on these dogs
that can sniff for COVID,
we went to this hills in Alabama, we had such a blast.
And then this year, we have an episode
that's all about the woman, Margaret Mitchell,
who wrote "Gone with the Wind,"
was killed in a drunk driving crash.
So we went to Atlanta.
All these trips end up going to Atlanta
'cause I love Atlanta.
But we ended up gonna her...
All of her papers where in Atlanta.
Then we went to the second half of the story,
it's too hard to explain now,
but it's all about the original "A Star Is Born" movie.
And the papers of that
are at the University of Georgia in Athens.
So we did this really fun road trip,
where we were wandering around Atlanta
recreating the crash scene and gonna Athens
and reading through hundred-year-old files.
We enjoy ourselves.
It just seems like such a heavy lift.
I just know I do the simplest version of this possible,
and I know how much it consumes my life.
To hear that, you go out, you do all that.
You have to bring it back, you gotta listen to all of it,
you gotta figure out what is the narrative here.
That's a challenge I would imagine
I won't be able to do it for ever.
Although I don't mean to, it's fun.
Like all things, it gets much easier the longer you do it.
And remember, before I started podcasting,
I had two previous careers.
One is a newspaper reporter, one is a magazine writer,
and they were enormously...
That kind of preparation is incredibly useful.
So the thing you learn, I was 20 years a newspaper reporter,
and what you learn in being a newspaper reporter
is efficiency, it's all about efficiency.
So it's about how quickly can I master a subject?
How quickly can I spot a story?
How quickly can I represent the story?
That was a 20 year long masterclass,
and I'm still living off those lessons I learned.
Where there's no room for writer's block.
No.
You're just bowling forward at all times
And that idea of zeroing in very quickly
on where you think the gold is,
that's what you learn as a...
I don't even know how you would learn it any other way.
But you're getting so many reps.
You might write four, five, six stories a week for 20 years.
Actually I wasn't a newspaper reporter for 20 years,
I was newspaper reporter for 10, I always doubled it.
It was 10 years, 10 years.
Is that a senior moment?
Well, I'm conflating it with my magazine stuff,
it was 20 years of newspaper and magazine.
So how does that leave you?
I know "Bomber Mafia" was audiobook first.
So how do you think about print media now?
When you consider that you can reach so many people
through the audio products
and you can do this fun creative stuff
and really elevate storytelling
in a way that nobody else is doing right now,
is there still an inclination to write a book book
or is it just like audio is where it's at,
this is what I'm doing now?
No, because I think it works in...
It's very hard to turn a written work
into a compelling bit of audio
if you don't have all the tape and all things.
But you can go in the odder direction.
So if you read "Talking to Strangers" for example
or "Bomber Mafia," but "Talking to Strangers"
was a book I wrote and from the beginning,
I had the notion that I was going to create
one of all kinds of special audio books.
It was gonna be an audio experience,
so I was collecting all the tape.
And the way the book is written
is very much it's written as if I'm reading it to you,
it's written in a conversational form.
And that, I think it totally works as a print book.
It feels a little different,
it feels more personal and emotional.
But if you go in that direction, from audio to print,
I think that works,
it's just hard to go in the other direction.
Well, and it also depends
on what kind of book it is, doesn't it?
Well, "Talking to Strangers" was a very emotional book,
it was a series of these very compelling narratives.
So yeah, for that kind of book, it works.
You couldn't do an economics textbook that way.
Right, right, right.
But it is interesting how entrenched legacy media is
in the way that they've always done things.
I know when I wrote my first book in 2012,
it wasn't even clear that there would be an audio book,
I almost had to talk them into it.
And then I did it, and the audio outsells the print,
and yet they still haven't really...
Now they take it more seriously
when you're negotiating your your deal.
They understand the value of the audio book,
when not that long ago, it was this cast away afterthought.
But still, they don't wanna put the time or the resources
into creating something of quality.
It's just go in a booth and make your thing.
Drive me crazy, drives me crazy.
You'd think they would like, oh this is the future,
we need to figure out how to be exceptional at this.
But usually sometimes they do it in-house
or they just find some third party company
to do it for them.
Rich, I hope you call Pushkin Industries
next time you have an audio book you wanna do.
I will definitely do that.
'Cause the more audio you do, you realize like, oh,
there's so much room for creativity here that is untapped.
And clearly Pushkin and your team,
you've realized this, you're an early mover in this space.
But I think you've only just tapped the tip of the iceberg
of what's possible.
The Paul Simon book we did, is a good example of this,
where it wouldn't work at all as a print book.
It was so far in the audio direction
where we just simply I called up Paul Simon and I said,
"I have an idea.
Me and my friend Bruce, let us come to you
and sit down and just have conversations
and just see where it goes."
And he said yes to my surprise.
So we went 10 times, we met with Paul Simon
in his various places, wherever he was in the world.
And we would encourage him to have a guitar in his hands
and we would record it,
and we were just like, see what happens.
We had 10, 5-hour conversations.
And we turned it into a six hour audio book
called "Miracle and Wonder."
And it is unlike any other audio book I've ever listened to,
I won't be so immodest to say it's better, it's different.
It's like it's not really a book, it's edited conversations
and then I wrote riffs on trying to make sense of...
The first chapter is,
what does it mean that he grew up in Queens in the '50s?
Does that shape the kind of music that he ends up making?
I think it does.
So we talked to him and then I give
or what's the significance, in retrospect, of Grace Land?
White guy goes to South Africa in early 1980s
and wants to sit down with south African musicians
and create something he doesn't know,
he can't tell you what it is 'cause he hasn't figured any.
He just thinks he would be fun to sit down.
Now, that has political implications, social implications,
it's the middle of apartheid, creative implications.
He produces one of the greatest albums of the 20th century.
How do we think about that in 2022?
So there's all this really cool things that come up
when you're talking to someone like that.
He's been musically relevant five decades,
how's that possible?
The thesis being that he's perhaps
the greatest rockstar of our time because of his ability
to maintain relevance over so many decades.
So this is a little hobby horse of mine, Rich.
When it comes to-
I know where this is going, go ahead (laughs).
When it comes to evaluating,
it's particularly true of athletes and artists,
when it comes to evaluating
the greatness of elite performers,
we overemphasize peak performance
and underemphasize longevity.
So I sometimes participate in the LetsRun running website.
Well, this came up in the extended blog post interview
that you did with David Epstein
and then LetsRun erupted in outrage over your thesis.
They are so wrong and I am so right.
So I said that Myer Nick Willis,
"Does not belong in the same conversation
as Matt Centrowitz."
And it was Willis is up here, Centrowitz is a step below
even though LetsRun said Matt Centrowitz
won the gold medal in the 1500 meters.
How can you say that Nick Willis,
who has never won a gold medal in any games is his equal?
And I would say well, the answer is
that Matt Centrowitz had one great shining moment,
that gold medal.
And he was a relevant runner for three-four year window
and had one very, very fast 1500 meters that he ran.
Nick Willis was relevant for 15 years.
He doesn't have a gold, but he had a silver in a bronze
in two separate Olympics separated by a lot of years.
He was a threat to win almost any race he entered.
For over a decade, his top three times
were all faster than Matt Centrowitz's times,
he's broken four minutes for the mile
in 20 consecutive years.
And I think as a culture,
we are somehow dismissive
of long periods of elite performance
and infatuated with brief windows
of extraordinary elite performance,
and I think that's wrong.
Well, of course, being as we're getting older,
we have a longevity bias.
David accuses you of being,
of course you're gonna over index on this
because we're getting old, right?
Absolutely, 100%, totally.
But it goes back to the beginning of our conversation,
when we were talking about kid sports.
We over index on the highest performers
and we're not paying attention
to how we inject these experiences with joy
to create lifelong pursuits.
You're right, this is exactly the same conversation.
Imagine that, Rich, I make you the athletic head
at one of these local high schools.
And you stand up in front of the entire school
on your first day in the job, what is the speech you give?
Now, I'm gonna put words,
I know the speech you're gonna give.
You're gonna write the speech for me.
Well, I know what you're gonna say.
You're gonna say, "I am here to create in you, teenagers,
a set of habits around physical exercise
that will stay with you for the rest of your life."
Right?
Mmm-hmm.
I'm gonna use my job as athletic director
to teach you how to live a healthy life.
And you're talking about healthy
in a sense of physical exercise,
but all those things as well.
'Cause that leads you into psychological health,
emotional health, that's your goal.
You are not gonna say,
"I'm gonna try and win as many California State titles
over the next five years as I possibly can."
You're not gonna give that.
And the tragedy is that everybody else who gets that job
says, "I'm here to win as many California titles
as I can over the next five years."
Everyone should give the speech you give,
that is the speech that's not being given.
And we are suffering as a country, as a society as a result.
Look around you, 1% of the population in middle age
is practicing healthy habits, why is that?
Because no one bothered to teach them
at the moment when those habits need to be taught.
So my argument about Nick Willis,
the idea of having a standard of performance
that spans 20 years, that matters, why?
Because when he 70, Nick's gonna be healthy
and running and competing, and that's what I want.
I don't care whether he's winning at 70,
but the idea that he could put together
a portfolio of running that starts in his teens
and ends in his 70s is something that makes me
just proud to be part of the same group of runners as he is.
Well, the animating force behind longevity is joy, right?
Sure.
You can't have
a longstanding career at a high bar
unless you're enjoying what you're doing.
So we have seen outstanding, excellent performances
from people who reach the very peak.
But then they burn out or they hate what they're doing
and they walk away from it,
never to participate it in it again.
So how do you ignite that level of joy and connection
to that pursuit that keeps you going?
So at your age, you're still interested in running
and training and all of those things,
and it brings joy and community into your life.
And if there's a great performance every once in a while
that comes out of that, great.
If not, who cares?
So I like that argument, it's very Gladwellian of course,
it's orthogonal to the way that we think about these things.
But you can't be intellectually honest about this
unless you recognize that that occasional
outstanding performer is the spark that inspires us all.
You need the Michael Phelps's and the LeBrons
to set this bar that gets us excited
about maybe engaging in that sport to begin with.
Yes
I'm not saying that I'm opposed to-
Look at how much
you talk about these fantastic track and field athletes.
Obviously, these are important to you.
They are.
But I also recognize that that set of values
applied to the body of the sport are counterproductive.
So what I'm arguing is, it goes back to the conversation
we had in the very beginning
about cross country teams should have 20 people on them,
and the 20th person should matter as much as the first.
That is not a...
I'm not saying we run
the world cross country championships that way.
But I do think we run the middle school
and the high school cross country championships that way.
In other words, it's time for us to understand
that there are two very different models here.
And that the models can be contradictory,
and we need to find a way foster them both.
And right now, the elite model,
the peak performance model is winning.
And that is driving a lot of young people out of the sport
and discouraging a lot of people and frustrating our attempt
to restore the health of our society.
And on that subject of health and and mental health,
as we touched on earlier,
did you see the story about Terry McKeever,
the head women's swimming coach at Berkeley?
No.
So she's considered the most legendary coach,
produced Olympians, world record blah, blah, blah
for decade after decade after decade.
And now coming out of the woodwork
are all of these former athletes of hers
telling tales of abuse and eating disorders
and suicides and the like
because that reign was marked by terror.
These young athletes being so terrified of their coach
and that coach holding them to such a high standard
that yes, it produces champions
but it produces a lot of carnage along the way.
And I feel like socially as a culture,
we're reckoning with that kind of legacy
modality of coaching in a healthy way.
But we're still purging ourselves
of the ills of that philosophy of sport.
Yeah, we have a long way to go in that.
Yeah, I know.
Well, before I let you go,
the final thing I can't let you go without asking you about
is so much of your work is about, as you just illustrated,
looking at things through a different lens
or deconstructing conventional wisdom.
What else, it doesn't have to be sports related,
is making you nuts right now?
Or what would you change
that you see around you in your daily life?
Oh, wow, the list of things that I'd like to change-
There's probably a lot, right?
In the world is so long.
And I didn't even get to education
That was gonna be whole hour of this podcast,
so maybe another time.
In the beginning.
I guess I would only say
I would follow up on what we've been talking about.
Which is, I have been thinking really long and hard
about competition and when it's useful and when it's not.
I'm someone who is deeply competitive
and who growing up there was not a game or a sport
or a thing that I didn't try to win at,
you know I'm that kind of person.
And now I'm beginning to understand
that there are lots of places
where that attitude is productive.
And not just in sports, but across all...
Like I was chatting with my brother, I saw him this weekend,
who's a retired elementary school principal.
I was talking about my obsession
with all this relative age effect stuff.
And he goes "Well," we were talking about possible solutions
and he goes, "Well, we don't have to rank and grade kids
under the age of 14 or 15.
There's no particular need to, what's at stake?"
We could start doing it at high school if you like,
but you could just stop grading them
in elementary school and middle school.
You could teach the same things
and keep tabs on who's behind.
My brother also, a very competitive guy,
was a fantastic athlete in this day, he's not...
But after 40 years in the public school system
as an elementary school teacher and principal,
he was like, "There's just no point to it."
Is this doing more hard than good?
And that's a really, really useful question
to start answering in a lot of domains.
That does bring up the education discussion though.
So much of education is premised on competition,
from the way that colleges are ranked,
and you have a whole thing about that,
to the whole ecosystem around getting kids into college
and what that means and what that doesn't mean.
That is so retrograde in so many ways
and does so much damage to young people.
Especially in this era in which
so much of what higher education is about is really detached
from what is necessary to be productive in the world.
I had a conversation last night with a friend
who was trying to figure out
where to send her daughter to school.
And she said, well, she really should go to, I think,
some college in Boulder.
UC, Boulder.
Probably.
'Cause she's outdoorsy, she likes to hang.
Well, when I suggested that to my daughter,
she burst into tears
'cause her daughter wants to go to a school
that other people think is a good school for her.
It's so weirdly detached
that objectively this is a place where she would be happy.
And yet she doesn't wanna go there
because the world tells her
that you have to go to a place that's ranked one through 25.
And schools being brands,
and these brands have a lot of power and resonance
in a way that is really damaging.
That's a whole thing, we should maybe do that another time.
One last thing, I had a conversation with Adam Grant,
we love to have these arguments every now and again.
I was thinking about what I would like to do
is in a very subversive way, screw up the whole system.
And I said to Adam, "What if you created schools
that had totally arbitrary admissions criteria?"
So what if you had a school where you said, all right,
in order to be considered for admission to our school,
you've gotta be able to break six minutes in a mile for men
and for women, 6:30, let's just say.
Well, let's have the bar a little higher for women.
Like just random shit like that and see what happens.
Well, if you got someone like Adam to design the testing,
you could select for the kind of people
that would get along with each other
and benefit from being in each other's company.
Would you like to go to an academically rigorous school
that was made up 100% of competitive athletes?
When I say competitive, people who take athletics seriously.
I actually think that would be super-interesting.
I don't know, would I learn something different
than the random school I went to?
Yeah, I think so, worth trying.
Then making that a reality is a whole different thing.
I know.
Thank you Malcolm Gladwell, I really appreciate your time.
Super-fun to talk to you
Thank you, Rich, thanks for having me.
That's fantastic.
"Legacy of Speed," Pushkin Industries,
you can find it wherever you listen to or find podcasts.
And Malcolm's pretty easy to find on the internet,
I don't think anyone's gonna have any trouble
tracking you down.
You got a newsletter,
what else do you wanna draw people' attention to?
"Revisionist History."
Season seven?
Seven drops this coming Friday, June 30th.
And it's all about experiments, right?
It's not out as of the moment we're recording this,
but I'm looking forward to that.
Anything that involves Australian swimmers, I'm in.
Yeah, it's all there.
All right, cool.
Well, come and talk to me again sometime I hope.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, peace.
(wistful music)